niko semlitsch von die partei heute die
wahl von frau von der leyen haben sie
für sie gestimmt gegen eine geheime wahl
aber wollen sie uns daran was an dieser
entscheidung ja ich habe sehr gut
gewählt ich habe heute auch für
transparenz werbung gemacht
dementsprechend habe ich sie nicht
gewählt kann ich ja auch ganz offen
sagen weil sie gegen transparenz ist
also ich weiß zum beispiel gar nicht was
ihre finanziellen interessen sind und
was ihre interessenskonflikte sind und
das finde ich sollte man schon wissen
hat sie sich auch ihrer partei ihnen
vorgestellt sie ist ja in den letzten
zwei wochen vor allen dingen auf die
fraktion zugegangen und hat hier
versucht auch für sich zu werben heute
ja auch nochmal mit einer doch sehr
starken rede hier im europäischen
parlament ja ich komme aus dem
showbusiness und was show angeht muss
ich sie loben die dramaturgie war gut
gesetzt das war ein schwacher start bei
uns in der fraktion heute eine gute
schlusspointe so und sie hat ja quasi
eine sozialdemokratische rede gehalten
und wenn ich nicht aus dem showbusiness
kommen würde wäre ich da vielleicht auch
drauf reingefallen
aber ich weiß das war eben show brauchte
ja auch und vielleicht auch deswegen was
ich jetzt heraus lese die
sozialdemokratischen noten in ihrer rede
zustimmung von den anderen fraktionen
glauben sie dass sie heute hier zur
kommissionspräsidentin gewählt wird weil
ich pessimist bin sage ich ja ich glaube
sie wird heute gewählt sagte nicole und
ich sage danke